all right gentlemen I want to thank you
all three for coming here today we
appreciate it and I'm going to ask you
if you would make opening statements if
you could hold your remarks to five
minutes as you can see we are a lively
panel with many questions and and
flights back late tonight so so I'm
going to ask to hold your remarks to
five minutes but your entire written
remark will be part of the record mr.
bienenstock did I start with you please
yes a good morning chair Warren and
panel members deputy chair Silver's mr.
mcwatters mr. mcwhorter and dr. trosky
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today since I've heard several times
that testimony is automatically in the
record I thought at least in part I
would try to supplement what I've
written by crystallizing some of what
I've heard this morning and tying it to
the relevant portions of my written
testimony first I I have no issue with
the emergency action taken by the Fed to
provide the 85 billion dollar facility
on September 15 2008 and you have more
information than i do but all i can say
is from what I've been able to read from
a lay person in the public are based on
the speed of the meltdown and the egg
tins exigencies of the situation on the
heels of the unrest you'd lehman
bankruptcy and collapse i don't know of
any alternative whether there could have
been some money from the private sector
i'm not sure at the end of the day we'll
even make a big difference because the
85 billion dollar facility was all
secured so the secured part will be paid
back hopefully it's over secured and the
government will get all its money back
at a profit but it was secured with
everything AIG had a value as far as I
can tell
uh what where I might take issue with
some of what has gone before both this
morning and in Prior hearings is the
notion that everything was set in stone
on September 15 and let me backtrack for
just a moment the speed and suddenness
of the need for the 85 billion dollar
facility while I can tell it's
surprising to many including some in
this room is not surprising to those of
us who have been through crises
involving trading companies before I met
with Enron the friday after thanksgiving
in 2001 and the next week it filed
chapter 11 when you're dealing company
financial statements and balance sheet
ages the assets and liabilities it also
changes the risk profile when the market
loses confidence in either the trader or
there's a pervasive market shift in
confidence in a class of securities such
as subprime the values fall out of bed
the financial statements are worthless
and you're at what I suppose AIG
considered the highly unlikely
occurrences in their computer models if
there was a fault there i think it was
governance at AIG that didn't recognize
the severity of the of the damage if the
unlikely did occur and there was no
preparation for that but each of these
are unique situations it's only the
speed of the death spiral that is the
same and whatever legislation arises out
of this it's very hard to script the
steps that should be taken I think
you'll find that the most important
thing is to have the risks fully
understood in advance so people are at
least ready to deal with them when they
do occur and each one is unique anyway
having having advanced the 85 billion
dollar facility on September 15 the
maiden lane two and three deals didn't
occur for several months later meanwhile
the the Fed had a lien on everything of
value AIG had over 30 million customers
which were 30 million creditors and the
creditors from which it really wanted
concessions and the notion of fairness
are the creditors who were trading in
the businesses creating the harm
primarily the credit default swaps and
perhaps the securities lending those
came down to the bulk of the exposure
being with eight counterparties the vast
bulk being with 16 according to other
testimony I've read including from mr.
Baxter and his few months ago so the
bottom line is there were months to talk
to the parties having the most exposure
about what concessions they might grant
if a if the government and AIG would
basically in partnership take them out
now what we know on the opposite end is
the government took the worst worst case
they already held 35 billion of security
and the government paid the full value
the par value remaining you can't do any
worse than them was done here hopefully
the government will be able to recover
much and all of that apparently it's
over secured from what I've read in mr.
millstein's testimony that you'll hear
later today it's currently over secured
but at the time we have to recognize
that the tables changed and the
essential message I want to give you is
this is a process you don't look at just
the end games once the loan was made
once AIG was secured 30 million
customers were current as well as its
other creditors AIG wasn't going to file
bankruptcy voluntarily and under those
circumstances no one could really file
in voluntarily because AIG was generally
paying its debts as they matured Thank
You mr. bienenstock I'm going to stop
you there but that's very helpful thank
you Mr Clarke I just want to say again
how much I appreciate your being here in
Standard & Poor's stepping forward to
give us some insight into the credit
rating process here if you could give us
your opening remarks yes thank you thank
you Thank You chairwoman Warren members
of the panel good morning my name is
Rodney Clark and I serve as a managing
director in standard & poor's rating
services and from 2005 through 2008 i
served as SNP's lead ratings analyst
covering AIG i'm pleased to appear
before you this morning at the outset
i'd like to take a moment to speak
generally about our ratings process and
to explain what ratings are and are not
intended to convey ESPYs credit ratings
are our current opinions on future
credit risk of an entity or a debt
obligation they express our opinion
about capacity and willingness of an
entity to meet all contractual and
financial obligations as they come to
S&P forms its rating opinions through
quantitative and qualitative analyses
performed by our rating analysts and
after an opinion is formed SMP publishes
the opinion in real time and for free on
our website and we generally publish a
more detailed narrative
our opinion this is the process by which
SP arrived at its ratings on AIG my
written submission includes a table
listing our global ratings history on
AIG since 1990 and a more detailed
description of our rationale for our
rating changes by way of overview up to
two thousand and five snps rating on AIG
was triple a our highest rating
reflecting our view that AI G's capacity
to meet its financial commitments was
extremely strong our opinion began to
change starting in march of 2005 and SP
has since lowered its ratings on the
company four times in February 2008 SP
announced a negative outlook for the
company's rating based on the way AIG
was determining the fair value of its
credit default swaps that it had entered
into AIG CD s guaranteed an array of
structured finance securities including
securities backed by sub prime
residential mortgages in May 2008 we
lowered our rating on AIG further to
double a minus and reaction to the
company's announcement of losses
including 5.9 billion related to its EDS
portfolio and we maintained a negative
outlook on a AG's rating throughout the
summer of 2008 in August SP announced
its view that AI G's actual
credit-related losses in the CD s area
would likely amount to eight billion
dollars with significantly higher
mark-to-market losses but the market
value of a I G's investments and the
investments of third parties that that
had purchased CVS guarantees
deteriorated sharply amid the
substantial market turbulence in
September 2008 in light of these events
on September 12 2008 SMP placed its
ratings on AIG and all AIG subsidiaries
on creditwatch with negative
implications on September 15th as a IGS
condition continued to deteriorate SMP
lowered its rating further to a minus in
light of increasing CD s related losses
and its reduced flexibility in meeting
the collateral needs in our view were it
not for the extension of an 85 billion
dollar borrowing facility by the federal
reserve bank of new york on September 17
2008
eh I jeez creditworthiness would have
continued to deteriorate our current
rating on AIG which remains a minus
includes a five notch uplift to account
for federal government support our
current view is that AIG has made
significant progress in reestablishing
its insurance market presence and in
implementing a very challenging
restructuring plan however we believe AG
remains two sets acceptable to
competitive regret competitive pressures
as well as aggressive market pricing
with respect to the effective AG's
current financial situation on the
creditworthiness of its subsidiaries we
believe those subsidiaries are to some
extent insulated by the state insurance
laws and regulations for example if AIG
had been forced into bankruptcy the
bankruptcy would have likely included a
relatively small number of AI G's non
insurance subsidiaries such as AIG
financial products with only a marginal
impact on AI G's insurance subsidiaries
nevertheless when SP lowered its credit
rating on AIG to a minus on sep tember
15th we also lower the ratings on most
of the insurance subsidiaries to a plus
where they remain today while a aiji's
financial problems have no direct effect
on the solvency of the insurance
subsidiaries we believe the
creditworthiness of those subsidiaries
is nevertheless indirectly affected by
the decreased likelihood that they could
receive additional capital from AIG as
well as the reputational risk resulting
from the parent company's financial
problems and its impact on customers
you've asked me to explain SNP's ratings
treatment of certain distressed
exchanges are criteria called for
consideration of various factors in
assessing whether a distressed exchange
would be viewed as a selective default
including whether default insolvency or
bankruptcy in the neuro medium term
would be likely without the exchange
offer just too well we just do one
sentence we've all read the Rourke and I
were at five minutes now the important
line then is every situation is
different and any significant discount
to the payment of the obligations other
than perhaps the
time value of money could potentially
constitute a default under our published
criteria thank you for the opportunity
to participate that was impressive thank
you mr. Clark to be able to take those
last pages and put together in a sense I
knew the important line that's right mr.
Moriarty could you could you like give
us your opening remarks please sir
surely please to I Thank You chair war
and another members of the congressional
oversight panel for the opportunity to
present any information to New York
insurance department can can assist in
Europe in fulfilling important charge
and there were some broad points I'd
like to make a number one AIG financial
holding company is not regulated by
state insurance regulators estate
insurance regulators are charged with
regulating the insurance operating
entities here in the United States in
that realm our job is to make sure that
policyholders are treated fairly and
that the insurance that they purchase to
protect themselves will be paid by the
insurance company when legitimate came
claims are put on the table number to
daj crisis with the primary result of
the credit default swaps issued by an
entity that was for all intents and
purposes in unregulated derivatives
shops are traded on the rating of AIG as
a whole during the crisis the feds main
concern was not the collapse of the
insurance companies which we don't
believe would have happened but AIG
financial products had cdss at futures
had other derivatives with many of the
major commercial banks and brokerage
firms the failure to perform on these
transactions would have a systemic
impact on the worldwide economy
especially since the counterparties to
AIG financial products were already
reeling from the failure of Lehman the
problem would bear stearns and extreme
stress at the other end financial
institutions the aggressiveness of AIG
bullish outlook on the residential
mortgage market did lead into the secure
and to the insurance companies in the
form of the securities lending when the
size of the securities lending program
in the life insurance companies became
known to the insurance companies in
terms of its size which is probably the
beginning of 2007
we with other states worked with AIG to
begin to wind down that securities
lending in an orderly fashion and did go
from a high of 76 million dollars in
2000 the beginning of 2007 down to fifty
eight billion dollars right before the
implosion of a AG in September of 2008
the crisis was caused the crisis caused
by financial products did spook the
borrower's of the securities lending
program and they would not let the
borrowings roll over as they had done in
the past and instead required that the
AIG returned the cash collateral that
was provided for them AAG had invested a
lot of that cash collateral in
residential mortgage-backed securities
which were underwater and failure liquid
and would have taken a significant loss
at the life insurance companies if those
collateral called made once the 85
billion dollar federal facility was
established by the Fed AG did take
advantage of that and use some of it 17
billion dollars worth to pay back some
of the borrower's of the securities but
the remainder of the SEC lending
portfolio remain kind of an albatross
around ahe as ago and concern main lane
to was formed in december two thousand
and a to effectively end a sec lending
program at the AIG life insurance
companies now for the nineteen point two
billion dollars that was provided by the
federal government for approximately
thirty nine billion dollars in par value
residential mortgage-backed securities
again they are being paid back and by
all indications they could make a profit
on it I think it's important to remember
that credit default swaps and security
landings are different transactions in a
securities lending program the borrow
post collateral if you do not return
that collateral they will keep these
securities that they borrow the AIG was
going to suffer a loss on the SEC
lending programs and and it's a
different transaction than a credit
default swap quickly in response to our
oversight of the AIG insurance company
as all states do we review insurance
financial statements and other ancillary
documents that are furnished by our
domestic insurance companies we do
on-site management and regular meetings
with the management at the time of
crisis AIG at 71 licensed insurance
companies in the United States seven of
those were domestic property casualty
insurance companies and three of those
were life insurance companies on Friday
we did get the call from the CFO of AIG
that a downgrade was imminent and it
would have dragged ramifications a team
of New York insurance department high
level representatives were sent to the
AIG office it was during that weekend
that the proposal to allow the property
and casualty insurers to effectively
swap 20 billion dollars of liquid assets
with some of the residential
mortgage-backed securities were put on a
table I just think it's important to
note that there were conditions to this
and that and that was that there was
capital provided by outside investors
and that the life insurance companies we
put underneath the pnc companies
effectively becoming subsidiaries of the
pnc companies very helpful Thank You mr.
Moriarty um so I want to be clear if I
can about setting the stage a little bit
for this panel uh if you've read the the
testimony from the Fed and we've had
multiple meetings now with the Fed they
basically have made the argument that
negotiation was simply not possible and
that it was not possible because it's
not possible because negotiation under
these circumstances particularly in the
case of rapid descent is is never
possible that ratings downgrades would
have triggered multiple cross defaults
and contagion throughout the market and
that the insurance regulators would have
seized the insurance companies and
therefore destroyed the value of the
entity ah and possibly caused losses to
the insured people around the country so
the reason we asked this panel to
um is that we wanted to probe that claim
that's that's what we're here about us
to just push back on this alternative so
I am going to start that I want to start
that if I can with you mr. Clark I'm
following the bail out of a hundred
cents on the dollar because the Fed has
described and they describing their
written testimony it was totally binary
it was either a full bail out with full
payment to everyone or it was no help
bankruptcy and collapse as they saw the
alternatives and so what I want to ask
here is following the Fed bail out there
was still a ratings downgrade right of a
i think i'm reading the you have some
slight readjustment no you're saying
following the the actual bail out the 85
billion the initial that's right okay
right I have some change in how your
rating AIG yes on sep tember the 17
following the the change we actually we
had lower the rating on the Monday to 15
to a minus on the Wednesday we
maintained the rating at a- we revised
the credit watch which indicates the
direction of possible movement from
negative because the trend was clearly
negative on monday to developing on
wednesday that implying could go up or
down but we were still sorting out the
impact of that it is this facility so
government help you had to evaluated
evaluate what its impact was going to be
at size the likelihood it would be there
in the future and i would assume from
the ratings you gave it was not
guaranteed that it would be there
forever otherwise it would have gone
back up to triple-a so so you were
trying to evaluate that and as we all
know AIG ultimately paid every creditor
100 cents on the dollar and has
continued to do so to this day so here's
my question i also read in your
testimony that right now AIG gets a five
notch improvement because of your
assessment of the value of the
government assistance if AIG had had a
negotiated settlement of some kind with
government assistance with private
assistance and
the haircut to the creditors of some
dollar amount would they have been
better off than if they paid a hundred
cents on the dollar or would they have
been worse off going forward into the
future what would have been their
financial picture if you can pay less on
your debt are you better off than if you
pay a hundred cents on the dollar on
your debt right and it's difficult for
me to explain in the hypothetical but I
know in our ratings criteria and
distressed exchanges which we shared
with the panel staff previously it
speaks to the fact that we would
consider a distressed payment of less
than what is owed to be a default or a
selective default under our ratings
criteria however it is true that in many
cases following a restructuring
following either a distressed exchange
or a series of distressed exchanges that
the credit condition could be better
than before the the time okay change
that was that was the part I needed and
then if one combined this distressed
negotiation with substantial funding
from some combination of private and
public sources what would the credit
rating look like going forward I I can't
speak to the hypothetical without
knowing the terms but it is possible
that it could have been similar better
or worse okay so I'll ask it in just the
other way and then I'm through and that
is was a foregone conclusion that their
ratings would be completely wiped out if
they paid something less than a hundred
cents on the dollar if they had secured
both government and private money going
forward under the criteria that we use
we look to was the counterparty paid
what they were owed and was it done in a
distressed situation that is to save the
company from insolvency or bankruptcy if
there were a modest discounts such as
relative to interest rates in the time
value of money that would not have
necessarily caused a default but those
are factors the rating committee would
would weigh in determining is the
exchange distressed or isn't it in
determining what the impact on the
ratings would be okay along with how
much money is available going for
absolutely all right good that's helpful
thank you very much
mr. McWatters thank you let me follow up
on that mr. Clark if there's a distress
exchange at the same time the government
has made commitments I mean has by this
time by November of 2000 they put in so
much money that it seems unlikely the
government is going to walk away from
that so at that point in time it's not
that AIG needs to do these distress
situations in order to save money for
liquidity because it has Uncle Sam
providing the liquidity it's ineffective
doing the distress transaction in order
to treat the taxpayers more fairly I
mean does that resonate with you at all
i believe so i'm not sure i'm hearing
the question well the question is is a
yeah we're going to kind of deal we're
in cut a haircut but the reason we're
cutting a haircut is not to save money
or liquidity of AIG because that's been
assured by the taxpayers by the Federal
Reserve Bank already putting in 85
billion dollars unlikely they're willing
to walk away we're going to cut a
haircut because that's fair to the
taxpayers the taxpayers are putting in
the money to take take these guys out
okay now understand the basis for our
ratings we've published a view that the
rating absent the federal support on AIG
today would be BB and suffice it to say
a year ago it would have been worse than
that however it's an a- rating with the
benefit of the government support that
is based on a view that the support that
exists is available to to allow the
company to meet its financial
obligations so it is fair to say that
that our rating committee would look at
a situation where AIG has significant
funding but isn't able to use it to
satisfy its financial obligations in
whole be it for the credit default swaps
or other obligations we would have to
form an opinion well will that funding
be available to future financial
obligations to pay them on time and in
whole and and so those are all factors
that we'd have to evaluate in
determining the appropriate rating and
it's been today the the credit facility
has been there for essentially all of
the financial obligations as needed if
that were not the case we'd reevaluate
the value of the support in the rating
okay so this is not a simple situation
that if there is one of these distress
exchanges therefore the wall falls down
okay mr. Bienstock I read your testimony
with great interest he seemed to present
an elegant alternative to what happened
and I think you were about to get into
that in your opening remarks would you
care to elaborate sure once the
government came forward with the 85
billion dollar facility and secured it
with everything of value as far as I can
tell the dynamics changed bankruptcy was
now off the table everything I've read
in the public record so far has been the
fed etc didn't want to threaten a bluff
about bankruptcy but now the strength of
AIG would say we're not voluntarily
filing and you can't involuntarily file
because we have over 30 million
creditors and we're paying 99.999% of
them on time in full so what is the
remedy now of those creditors you think
who was a matter of equity to the
taxpayers should provide a discount the
remedy is not a lot they can go at most
to state court at the cost of great
public notoriety some of these entities
had government assistance separately
other of these entities for instance
purchase Lehman Brothers for 250 million
dollars plus the appraised value of the
real estate at receive and then had to
acknowledge in its sec filing a 3.5
billion dollar profit on the purchase
I'm saying as a matter of common sense I
don't think these entities were in a
position to say to the US government no
we won't make some moderate but
meaningful concession in exchange for
taking us out entirely of these credit
default swaps remember
that's what was done they were paid a
hundred sense so and we could always go
or AIG could always go to the rating
agency and say look we're only asking
for concessions from businesses were
winding down we're not doing more of
this foolishness and as far as all our
insurance companies are all ongoing
businesses we have the facility there
it's available for payment in full on
time okay Thank You mr. Silver's mr.
Bienstock your your your response just
then when in your view I mean this let
me to first get clip straight this is
your this is your profession is it not
giving advice in these types of
situations these highly pressurized
insolvency crises yes mr. Silver's right
when when are you suggesting that the
approach that you just outlined would
have best been deployed by the Federal
Reserve once they after the first thing
was to stabilize to provide the 85
billion facility then in discussions
with those people who should equitably
give concessions over the next several
weeks months they took until November
and December to close their deals so
they had plenty of time to do but
essentially as soon as it was as soon as
you're saying as soon as it have been
made clear to the markets in general
around the systemic risk issues and the
like that a simple chapter 11 filing was
not yeah to give you a bit more of a
professional response and she said this
is my profession right what I would say
to the client is after you've taken care
of your lifelines now who were AI geez
lifelines first speak to mr. Clark to
explain exactly what's going on why this
will improve credit worthiness going
forward and not endanger others after
explaining to employees customers etc
here's how we're going forward then once
you've got your lifelines intact once
the government which is the revolving
credit facility lender knows what you're
doing now is the time to do
but mr. Moriarty yes you it has been
represented to us and I think you heard
some of it this morning that absent what
the Fed did and precisely the way it did
it there would have been a crisis for
the insurance subsidiaries and their
ability to maintain their business pay
their obligations and the like a crisis
that so serious that avoid that was
absolutely necessary to rescue the
parent and the manner the parent was
rescued in order to avoid such an
outcome I think there is a kind of in
implicit analysis made by the Federal
Reserve and and the treasury and saying
so that whatever problems might have
arisen in the insurance subsidiaries
that would have been beyond the ability
of the state insurance regulation and
the guaranty system to manage what is
your response to both those propositions
and specifically what was the view of
the new york state insurance regulators
and the the forgotten the term of art
now but there's a sort of coordinating
body of state insurance regulators what
was the or view during the so-called
Lehman weekend around these questions
sure I'd like to bifurcate my answer and
into two parts we do not believe that
the existing policy holders of the AIG
property and casualty companies for sure
or even the life insurance companies of
would have suffered any losses should
there would there have been a bankruptcy
of the AIG holding company system state
insurance law through the
mccarran-ferguson act clearly gives us
the authority to regulate insurance
companies and to rehabilitate and
liquidate them which is a different
process from a bankruptcy so we would
maintain that the the existing policy
holders would have been made whole even
if there was a bankruptcy the life
insurance subsidiaries would have
suffered significant losses and the
cushion which we call surplus which is
effectively capital between assets and
liabilities would have to take in a
severe head but we still think it would
be positive
now when we look at AAG as a going
concern that that would have been a
problem clearly reputational risk of a
bankruptcy at the holding company level
could shake the confidence of the
policyholders on a property and casualty
side much of the business is placed by
three big brokers if they blacklisted
AIG from for all intents and purposes as
a going concern not that they would be
gone same on the life insurance side I
saw the to the extent that there was a
bankruptcy did there would be a concern
as to the the ability of the AIG
company's insurance companies to proceed
as a going concern that being said that
there there are options there could be
sales of the book of business to
existing insurance companies there could
be transfers of certain parts of the
books to other companies so I mean there
could have been some money moved around
that could have been rebranding a I mean
it's hard to speculate but clearly the
bankruptcy would have had in a
troublesome impact not asking you to
speculate but just to remember did you
all communicate a view that did your
department or did to your knowledge
other insurance regulators communicate a
view to the film to reserve order the
Treasury during this period that the
parent of AIG had to be rescued in the
manner that it was rescued no he didn't
did you make any of you at all to the
fed to New York Fed or the Treasury when
we were at the Fed beginning beginning
Saturday morning and I think it's clear
from the governor Patterson's offer new
york and pennsylvania at the time which
were the two lead regulators of the
property and casualty companies did see
an opportunity to basically lend AIG FP
20 billion dollars in more marketable
securities and we would take over the
the less liquid residential
mortgage-backed securities we did that
again on the premise that number one
that there would be a new capital
provided in AIG Inc by
so I'd investors and number two that the
life insurance subsidiaries and that's a
value of the life insurance subsidiary
would be put underneath the pnc company
so we were looking for a guess you call
it a private savings but it had to be a
global solution it had to be part of a
solution that would allow a IJ to
continue making its way through the
financial crisis anything short of that
I think we'd be highly reluctant to let
any money come out of the the property
and casualty insurance companies okay
thank you mr. up professor troszke thank
you um guess maybe I'll start with you
mr. Bienstock and you can help because
one of the things I've haven't
understood about AIG in particular is
the claim the claim that seems to be
made that had a IG under bankruptcy they
would have simply ceased operating which
seems somewhat different than most
companies that actually do enter
bankruptcy of the recent experience of
Chrysler and General Motors and a
variety of airlines as any example
companies often do enter bankruptcy and
workers get up the next morning go to
work and continue to produce products do
you have any sense of why what's
different about an insurance in this
instance and Chrysler or General Motors
or you know United Airlines who all or
yeah I think so the the clear
distinction is that trading operations
can only trade when there's confidence
in the marketplace that's why an Ron's
trading ceased before it filed its
chapter 11 petition that's why a IGS
would also additionally there's when you
say tray do you mean their securities
trading not their insurance business not
know i'll get to that the the insurance
companies are subsidiaries that are
ineligible to go into bankruptcy they
could be seized by state regulators or
not but they would not technically be in
bankruptcy themselves there might be in
state proceedings but at the holding
company of the various op non insurance
operations of the Bankruptcy Code
special provisions for derivatives
trading that it allows counterparties to
terminate and to liquidate that's the
thing that doesn't operate the rest of
the operations that are if there are any
more like the airlines the auto
companies they can continue to I don't
think AIG had money that type of
operation okay and mr. Morey you you
made the the claimant and this is the
claim that's often made in it was a
claim that was made auto companies of
why they couldn't enter bankruptcy
because the warranties all of a sudden
you know who's going to buy a car from a
bankrupt car company because you know
you got no guarantee that that that you
could you know they were going to be
around to protect the warranty of course
the warranties can also often be
provided by 3rd party people do it all
the time and so again when I look at it
as an economist if there's value being
produced somebody's going to produce
that value because they what they want
to make a profit in a market-based
economy so if if AIG had valuable
entities even going into a part of the
company went bankrupt somebody's got to
be able to step up and continue to
provide the services they do albeit
maybe under a different name does that
seem like a reasonable outcome I i think
it is again there are reasons that the
state insurance laws wall off the assets
and liabilities of the insurance
entities from all the non insurance
entity simply because the assets are
meant to pay the policy holder claims
AIG as one of the former panelists
indicated employed over a hundred
thousand people worldwide there were
less than 500 people employed by AIG FP
which arguably brought down or severe
stress to AIG may aj clearly had a lot
of talent in terms of its core
businesses which was probably
unconscious the insurance and and life
insurance and those subsidiaries could
have been sold the business could have
been taken by other entities I you know
I think they're there were options i
think the policyholders number one would
have been paid and number two probably
could have gotten
new coverage whether from company it was
sold by aig or commercial account i just
went to ahe i do think that one of two
of the concerns that we were most
concerned about with respect to AIG was
number one that they would lose
customers because of the reputational
risk and that they would lose good
people because of the reputational risk
those are those are concerns that are
you know still remain with us that's
that's some different than any business
said I mean presumably you know do you
want to fly on an airline that's
bankrupt um I mean I when I get on an
airplane I sort of do depend on their
way the person driving it and and if I'm
you know that I got to think that those
concerns may be even more paramount I
think I'm more concerned when I get on
an airline and then about my life
insurance policy Oh a good insurance it
is a promise to pay it is it yes don't
make widgets and it doesn't make call it
an airline is a promise to get you there
alive yeah I'm correct okay um but
behind it but I understand your point
and I I do agree with you let me one
more quite mr. um I had I'm sorry ahead
of ya ever mr. Clark so we discussed
today about the combination of a private
sector public sector you know that veil
of financial support for AIG how would
that have affected had had the federal
government put in less money private
sector put in more can you speculate a
little with that of effect of the the
ultimate rating of AIG in your mind no
we'd be looking to the outcome in terms
of AI geez sources of liquidity its
ability and willingness to meet its
obligations when do whether that funding
was private public or a mixture that
wouldn't have offended wouldn't have
affected our our rating okay thank you
thank you good thank you Oh mr.
bienenstock I think you were in the room
to hear mr. Baxter explain the role of
the Fed and the long-term capital
management negotiations and I think his
words were that the Fed explained to the
creditors what was in their own best
interests in reworking what needed to be
done it
can you talk about what kind of
conversation I might have occurred with
the counterparties to AIG and what was
in their own best economic interest I
think you hit this but I just want to
make sure we got this one nail down I'm
sensitive to the concern of the Fed not
to use its regulatory power in a debtor
creditor capacity where they're serving
as a lender so I'll phrase it as to what
any 800-pound gorilla lender such as one
of the big banks or in this case the Fed
would have said to the other creditors
and the answer is we're taking a lien on
everything Bank in this case it's unique
as I said because bankruptcy was taken
off the table for other reasons we're
taking a lien on everything bankruptcy
is not an option we're willing to do a
transaction with you if you make a fair
concession for the benefit of all
taxpayers because if not for our money
you would have taken a big loss on us
for the most part and what are your
options your options are to do nothing
in which case we won't do a transaction
you won't have more money from us we
won't buy out your CDO your option
should go to state court will argue a
while about whether you're entitled to
more collateral and how much more and by
that time the underlying dynamics will
have changed but at the end of the day
you're not going to have a remedy that
really gets you value because we're
sitting here with an 85 billion dollar
weaned and you'll be in the newspaper
and on the news every night trying to
frustrate the United States government's
effort to save the global financial
system now what would you like to do
okay I think we have that um can I can I
ask you one other that that comes out of
your testament or your written testimony
and then as you talk about shared pain
the principle of shared pain and
bankruptcy can you just elaborate a bit
on that sure uh we all grow up being
told that when we make a promise we keep
it when we give our word we keep it and
one of the things that makes bankruptcy
counterintuitive and frankly offensive
to a lot of laypersons
that in bankruptcy if a debtor breaks
one promise takes one creditor and
doesn't pay it but pays its others
that's pretty unfair so the more fair
procedure is to break all its promises
and to share the pain equally across all
the creditors that's where bankruptcy is
contrary to most of our notions of
substantial justice so sharing the pain
is the way of one the creditor being
hurt or the lender coming up with
innocent taxpayer money saying it's
unfair that we're taking all the pain
you're getting paid a hundred sense for
a business that couldn't have paid it if
we had not come to the rescue you have
to share equally because that's fair
okay thank you very much mr. Bienenstock
I'm through mr. mcwatters Thank You mr.
Bienstock when I was reading your
written submission again I was struck by
the elegance of it rather the simplicity
of it and which made me think well why
wasn't is done why didn't other people
think of this then I got to page four
and you say on page four you say
additionally the Federal Reserve Bank of
New York retained an outstanding law
firm and attorney for its work but the
law firm is identified with representing
Wall Street institutions such as
JPMorgan and it would be awkward for it
to devise strategies to obtain
concessions from those institutions
could you help me understand that sure
in this case I think it sounds to me
because of the exigent exigencies of
time the law firm that was probably
familiar with the situation other than
AIG zone law firms was the law firm
being used by JP Morgan and Goldman
Sachs to try to come up with a private
solution which I heard earlier I think
was a Monday September 15 effort yes so
since they had immersed themselves in
the documents i suppose that least that
was one factor why with waivers granted
and full disclosure and all the rest
this was all done properly I'm sure that
JP Morgan and Goldman Sachs
surrendered their council effectively to
the Federal Reserve Bank of New York
those council are they are outstanding
as I said both as a firm and the
individual who was leading it but they
are known to represent the Wall Street
interests not that they don't represent
others but they're synonymous in the
restructuring industry with representing
the Wall Street interest so it would be
awkward as I said for them to
concentrate on well here's how we might
get concessions from counterparties who
are their clients in in many other
matters well I assume this is
particularly true given that two weeks
from now we'll be back representing JP
Morgan and JP Morgan they say yeah
you're the guy that just came and
representative fed and came to us and
beat us up for a concession well and i
want to emphasize this was done i think
the federal reserve bank of new york
people said earlier this was done with
full waivers etc it was done totally
properly it's allowed to be done and
it's often done in this case I just
think it put council in an awkward
position and also you've heard there are
a lot of explanations I mean not
everyone gives my analysis certainly
maybe no one did and there were a lot of
explanations that were facile for people
to latch on to why you should just pay
all the creditors all the time correct
one last question if on September the
16th I came to you and retained you and
said we've just given this entity 85
billion dollars vicinity AIG 85 billion
dollars and it's on 180 days is a bridge
can you work out a prepackaged
bankruptcy of AIG working with the
insurance companies the rating agencies
and the like within 180 day 180 days in
reach resolution I would have told you
less than a ten percent likelihood and
let me just amend something i said
before i did before today test with
restructuring experts both business and
legal the idea of getting
sessions and I was surprised to find out
yet got unanimous buy into that on the
pre pack the reason I'm saying less than
a ten percent likelihood is as a matter
of right any creditor can ask for an
examiner God knows there was a lot to
examine here I think that's what you're
doing that can take months or years I
would caution you that if you're doing
the bankruptcy 80 after the 85 billion
dollar revolver has been extended that
85 billion is subject to restructuring
in bankruptcy like all the other debts
sure uh we we pre packaged as a term
used most technically for making a deal
with everyone in advance going to court
and asking for swift approval of the
plan it basically works when you have a
small group of sophisticated parties or
you're just paying everyone in full here
if the decision had been made to pay
everyone in full then my answer of less
than a ten percent probability would
change I would say if you're going to
pay everyone in full in that prepac then
yes you can more likely than not you can
do it in a hundred eighty days but if
you're not paying everyone in full I
would say the likelihood of dealing with
millions of people who have guarantees
for their insurance policy thousands of
other types of creditors including
derivative creditors in six months it's
nearly impossible okay well thank you
then and that helps support your
solution that you have in your paper
thanks Thank You mr. Silver's mr. Clark
you like mr. Moriarty have been assigned
responsibility by our national
government for much of what has happened
here by you I mean your firm and the
other credit rating agencies I I want to
offer you the opportunity to if you
dispute what's been said about the
rating agencies by our other witnesses
to do so but I want to also ask you a
very specific question about about a
different way of thinking about the
options available which is if rather
than rescuing the parent all right the
no reserve had chosen to make 13-3
lending available to subsidiaries on an
as-needed basis would would it have been
possible to have maintained the same
level of credit rating in your by your
by your agency and others that was
effectuated by rescuing the parent and
just to make this question a little bit
more cut further more complicated do you
agree with mr. Moriarty's assessment
that the subs could have handled the
their problems around securities lending
absent the absent the problems of the of
the over-the-counter derivative is pneus
at the parent level that's complicated
it's complicated well three distinct
questions one open ended the second
question is the second question is could
you have maintained the creditworthiness
of the subs directly and let the parent
go or have the parent have go through
something like perhaps what mr.
Bienstock was talking about and thirdly
mr. Moriarty right that the subs could
have handled the could have handled the
securities lending problems without
further assistance okay i'm going to
leave the open-ended one on the table
but if the New York Fed had lent
directly to the the subsidiaries I don't
know that they had the authority to do
that and I can't really speak to whether
that would have helped the subsidiaries
remember the credit ratings without
understanding what the terms would have
been well let's just assume that we're
talking about essentially what happened
to the parent a blank check under 13 3
and you can lend to anybody under 13 3 I
think that's kind of what we've learned
that let's just I don't want a legal
opinion about whether the Fed have the
authority let's just assume the Fed open
the spigot to the subs mm-hmm could
they've opened the spigot wide enough to
maintain the credit rating of the subs I
presume that they could have it's much
much more complicated when you look at
the fact that by lending to AIG there's
sort of your filter to get money down to
the subs but when you talk there a
filter with a giant hole in it called
credit default swap
understood but that was only one of the
places that those funds coming from the
New York Fed we're going and when you
look at the literally hundreds when you
start looking globally of regulated in
unregulated subsidiaries of AIG I think
it would have been very difficult to get
money to all of those in addition you
had cross guarantees between certain of
the subsidiaries both domestic and
foreign which most often went back to
insurance companies regulated in New
York or Pennsylvania not always it was a
very complicated web of relationships
really just necessitated by the complex
global nature of the group so it's much
simpler to do at the parent it was much
simpler to do it but it but you're not
saying that you couldn't have done it I
don't know that under their authority
they could or couldn't no I'm not her it
wouldn't obligated the task right what a
company on the task okay mr. do you
agree with mr. Moriarty that that the
resources were available to subs to deal
with with with the securities lending
problem I think it's it's possible that
they could have I do think though if you
if you look at what happened between
September 15th and and really the end of
the year when the enormity of the
financial crisis the the continued
investment losses not only on the
securities lending program but on other
investment holdings of a aiji's
insurance companies and many other
insurance companies in the industry that
there was a drain there and AIG through
its resources from the New York Fed did
inject significant capital into the
domestic life insurance companies could
they without that the drain of the CD s
have handled that themselves given the
continued decline of the financial
markets possibly but it's difficult to
say with any certainty one more question
is it possible in your in your opinion
for major insurance player company to
operate with a BB credit rating it
depends on the businesses that they're
in something their diverse assuming
maybe pragmatics of you I mean assuming
a diversified range of businesses life
in pnc its past and investments it's
possible and we see it in certain areas
certain areas of insurance or more
confident sensitive than others
when you look at some of a aiji's
businesses that were in high net worth
life insurance and annuities those are
very confident sensitive vulnerable to
run on the bank in a in a severe stress
and the and the large commercial
insurance similarly not a run on the
bank risk but very sophisticated
purchasers of insurance who value credit
and would be unlikely to purchase or a
new business BB is below lilo the line
and yeah definitely or in most buyers
views it would mr. Marley dude I
couldn't tell with you agreeing or
disagreeing I no no I disagree my
colleague again the cup the commercial
side of the business whether it be on a
property side of the high worth net
individual very rating sensitive and and
do do due diligence in terms of the
creditworthiness of the insurance
companies that they're dealing with for
some personal lines like auto and
homeowners and arguably they can write
at the lower levels but something below
investment grade even would be difficult
to write any extensive book of business
I have one more quick come quick mr.
bean and stock can you exert you help us
understand from your general knowledge
of this of these markets and so forth
JPMorgan Chase and AIG what was their
mutual dependency here of some kind of
during this period GI I'm not any
insight into this i'm not familiar with
their uh their contractual relationships
okay thank you thank you dr. troszke
thank you mr mori i guess i'm going to
ask a general insurance question and i'm
going to try to put it in simple terms
as possible because I think sometimes we
get a little confused by the jargon AIG
was writing credit default swaps where
essentially they were insuring mortgage
backed securities out of financial
products yes some of them while
simultaneously the company was also
purchasing mortgage-backed securities
correct so they were actually purchasing
products that they were also ensuring
toppling down yes yes um I'm no
financial expert nor am I expert in
insurance that seems
rather odd to me that a company would
both ensure something and then expose
themselves even further to the risk that
that they're ensuring is that is it
usual for insurance companies to double
down in this fashion no it's not
actually usually try and make sure that
the risk on on the asset and a liability
side are do have some don't have a high
degree of correlation when we first
looked at this exact lending program was
it was covered by Texas which has one of
the biggest life insurance companies and
they were doing a an examination and and
and no they just noted that this thing
was growing exponentially and alerted
other states at the time LG management
had come in to the regulator's to
explain the program and now we expressed
concern about two things number one was
a sergeant number one was the fact that
they were investing to cash and
securities that were longer dated than
the liabilities on the on the securities
lending so they depended on the counter
parties who effectively roll over or
else they'd have to liquidate the
securities then we went into the
diversity of these securities which were
sixty percent in over sixty percent in
residential mortgage-backed securities
which was clearly a high amount but they
brought up the point these world
triple-a rated they will double A rated
residential mortgage-backed securities
that were in fact diversified because
they came from different originator
'he's the collateral was spaced
throughout the country the basically the
mortgages and there hasn't been a
meltdown of the residential mortgage
across the country in the united states
in in a long time fifteen years and and
and and and so again from their
viewpoint it was an imprint was an
imprudent activity and gave them more
investment yield but nonetheless the
sheer size of it and the concentration
in your invest that they did at our
behest us begin a significant downsizing
of it with
reporting big losses and they reduce it
by twenty-four percent in a year from 76
billion down to fifty eight billion
dollars and we do things that now again
absent the the issues at FP and the
financial crisis and that the SEC
lending program would have been wound
down let me let me dumb make ask another
question to it and it's actually when
you're doing this when you're sort of
both ensuring and purchasing it you
exacerbate the risk because now you've
got what's known as a covariance the way
the two of them move together because
typically you only have to worry about
how the changes the potential changes in
one so it's actually very important if
you're doing both to understand how the
things you're purchasing are going to
vary with the things that you're
insuring then I tell you I totally agree
with your doctor I think one of the one
of the issues though is that we regulate
the insurance company we right now right
and I'm asking you is just as an
insurance expert not as that you should
have been overseeing this because I
don't want to imply that so let me and
mr. Clark so as mr. Moriarty um
indicated that these were all triple
rated securities are double rated but
but your when you take insulin and again
I'm going to be real simple here and
this is not particularly what you've
come to talk to us about but when they
were coming to you with essentially a
box of mortgages and SP was giving a
rating on those mortgages you were
rating the mortgages in a box and then
sell it and then the bank would go out
and sell them to somebody but what a IG
now had is they had they were ensuring a
box over here and they were buying a box
over here and you're not evaluating how
those two boxes are going to move
together which is a key point for AIG if
they're but if they're both ensuring and
buying that you're not evaluating the
covariance between those two investments
are you well your triple-a just tells me
about that the the likelihood of loss
from these mortgages I own not let me
separate out what I can and can't answer
okay well I'm an analyst in our
insurance ratings practice responsible
for AIG oh I can't speak to how the
ratings were arrived at in structured
fine
I can speak to the analysis we did on AI
geez securities lending and it's okay
that would be great it's c.d.s
portfolios and and we were throughout
2008 analyzing those portfolios and
making projections which we updated
publicly to the market throughout the
year as to our expectation of losses
that the firm would would would likely
see on those portfolios both we were
looking at both and we were combining
the analytics what we saw however was
that in the fall of 2008 and very much
to mr. Moriarty's point that we we'd
seen housing declines before but one on
a nationwide scale of this depth of
magnitude that was really outside of our
assumptions and the assumptions of many
in the market it was it was quite
unprecedented so we did find that the
performance of both of those portfolios
although we modeled them together looked
at the exposure together the eventual
losses did exceed what our expectation
key were good thank you very much I want
to thank all three panelists mr.
Bienenstock mr. Clark and mr. Moriarty
we appreciate your taking the time to be
here with us today this has been very
helpful to the panel and will be very
helpful to our report we're going to a
call a recess for this panel for half an
hour we'll start again at a quarter of
two and our first witness at that point
will be Clifford Galan thank
bring his back in session I want to
welcome mr. go on